Joining me, right now, live, and in person,
I have an incredible co-pilot.
She is the brilliant writer and comedian
transforming late night TV, as we know it.
And you can watch her razor sharp variety show
Ziwe on Showtime, which, by the way,
just got picked up for season two, take a look.
I'm honored that you you're doing the show,
but my question is, why did you agree to this?
Do you know who I am?
I don't have the slightest idea here.
(emotional piano melody)
Someone who worked for you was incredibly persistent,
incredibly persistent to the point
where this just seemed easier.
So shout out to the persistence of women of color. Really.
(laughter and applause)
Please welcome one of my personal idols.
Ziwe Fumudoh!
(cheering and applause)
Thank you! Thank you for having me!
I have already gotten our picture taken.
I asked her to join us in our brand new digital hub
to kick off, you know, what that is.
There's no better way to establish,
honestly, anything than being with you.
Your interview style is, is so unique.
Not only do I want to ask you advice,
but when I watched the Fran Lebowitz piece
and the way that you unveil people
and take off their armor piece by piece
with a very well-researched, very extremely unique approach,
you know,
you're, you are a good person.
Like, what's your take on the Fran Lebowitz,
you know, interview.
I love the Fran Lebowitz interview.
I just think she's so honest and vulnerable.
And Fran has been,
she has been interviewed for decades, right?
We've heard Fran speak
and to get new perspectives from her in 2021. Wow.
I'm proud!
I just love your style.
All right. Let's get into the news.
I want to talk fashion.
Yes.
New York city is still buzzing
after last week's Met Gala.
Yeah.
It was fashion week, of course.
And the thing we didn't know we needed.
Larry David turned out to be the star of fashion week
when he showed up to the Staud spring show
and did this.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
Ziwe, what? Is it that loud? What is it?
I was actually at that show
and what was ironic is that
there was a celebrity dog next to me
and a producer approached the dog and said,
there's going to be loud noises.
And I think that, you know,
maybe other guests at the show
clearly could have benefited from that warning. So--
(Drew laughs) Could the dog take it?
Cause they really do have the sensitive hearing.
No, the dog was also cowering.
So, but ultimately it was a gorgeous show.
So worth it!
(Drew laughs) All right.
Well also Larry has been out and all about
and spotted with fashion icon
slash actor icon
slash every girl's dream wishlist it-guy,
Timothée Chalamet.
They've been hanging out
and drinking, like, espresso martinis.
By the way, Timothée Chalamet looks 10.
(audience laughs)
Like, he-- the baseball hat and the vest
is not doing his maturity any favors.
What do you think, Ziwe?
Tell me everything you were thinking of
when you look at this picture.
Gogo gaga. I love the range that we're getting.
I like an intergenerational friendship.
I personally look forward to having friends who are,
you know, later in life.
And so I respect that
because it's like, okay, I'm--
From Timothée Chalamet,
You could get advice about vests.
From Larry David,
you can get advice about great prescriptions.
It's a great, it's a symbiotic relationship.
And I think we need to honor and respect that.
I love that.
Okay Ziwe, it's your story.
Okay, so, everyone is talking about the hot new couple
Channing Tatum and Zoe Kravitz
seen leaving the Met Gala together.
Oh yeah.
Drew, are you excited about this new couple?
I feel like it might be
really one of the hottest couples
in a long time.
They emanate heat. Like I can,
I feel like the ozone layer is cracking
because of the--
what they're expelling together
when they get into union.
They might be a danger to the planet.
(audience laughs)
This much chemistry might take us all down.
I mean, no, but seriously, like,
I know what it would look like
if I was hanging out with someone.
It's like couch, delivery food, TV,
sweatpants, hangout sesh.
Yeah.
Okay vibes. Okay!
(audience claps)
And I feel like they have a record player
and they're dirty dancing
and like, there's like a pizza in the corner
on the floor with some candles around
and it's just like the hottest night ever.
Yes, absolutely.
I wonder if Channing and Zoe were actually friends first
before they became a couple.
Well, I do happen to know that,
and this is according to Deadlines,
sort of our industry's, you know,
one of their more reliable sources
that she's actually directing a film
and he is attached to it.
So maybe collaboration equals friendship
equals into relationship.
Ziwe, talk about your next story
'cause this does dovetail.
Well, according to a new study,
that's how most people prefer to start a relationship.
As friends first.
Well and Good reports that
they surveyed over 2000 adults
and 66% said they were friends with their partner
before they got together.
Drew, do you like the friends before lovers approach
or does that cause some hazard?
One time it caused real hazard.
Ooh.
We were literally besties.
We traveled the world together.
We got ready for things together.
We were each other's like dates to things together.
We poured our hearts out. We dealt with other relationships,
Like with and for, like to help each other.
We were besties for years.
And then one night, he looked at me different
and I was like, what?
And we had that evening.
And then the next time I saw him, I, of course, in my head,
I'm like, oh, we have everything.
We're best friends. We-- there's nothing we can't do.
And now with this new element,
we might be the ultimate couple.
And I showed up at our next thing
and I had that, like,
I wasn't looking at him the same way anymore.
And he was like, oh, and then I was like,
you had to ruin this over a night?
This, what--
and then I got mad and then we didn't speak for years.
Wow.
And now we're still friends and
both married with kids
and, you know, with statute of limitations,
everybody's sort of just
has to forgive their journey in life.
So I feel like both parties have to
clearly be on the same page about it.
And how many people in the audience
believe that friendship leads to a relationship?
Show of hands.
Okay. 66% of people in the Well and Good study said
that they believe that.
Yeah.
What's your personal take on this?
I don't have love in my life
and I'm actually really self-conscious about that.
I'm single! I love it!
Okay.
(audience laughs)
Mine's like super by choice, but,
and by the way, no one asked me out.
So there's that too.
Vibes, vibes, vibes.
It's hard. You know?
People don't approach--
Beautiful geniuses. No, I get it.
Do you get asked out?
No.
We're unpacking a lot.
We're all friends, here.
That's what we do on this show.